yeah so it's great to see everyone i
feel like i haven't seen
seen a lot of people from the broader
community outside of
stanford for a while so
today i'm going to be talking about
learning exploration strategies via meta
reinforcement learning
and before i start kind of a quick
disclaimer is that
the problem that i'll be talking about
is in many ways very
quite different from the classic
exploration problem
uh but hopefully that will also make it
potentially
also kind of an interesting new thing to
be thinking about
so the first is some motivation uh
i like to think about why humans are are
good at reinforcement learning if we
think about how humans might want to
learn how to play a new card game
or learn how to use a coffee machine or
learn how to
kind of figure out how to manipulate
objects
to pack a dishwasher or play a game like
this where you need to
balance different different game pieces
humans are really good at learning these
kinds of things uh
they they can probably learn them a lot
faster than most reinforcement learning
systems that we have now
and the reason why humans i think are
really good at learning these kinds of
things
is that people have previous experience
we've already built up a representation
of the world that facilitates
exploration and learning
of these tasks we may have learned other
card games
we've maybe used other coffee machines
or manipulated dishes before
so that we can we can have a reasonable
idea for how to figure out how to solve
these tasks
whereas in contrast our reinforcement
learning agents start tabular rasa
they don't have any previous experience
we're starting them completely from
scratch from a clean clean
slate and while this has a lot of
benefits because you don't have to build
any knowledge
into the system itself it also means
that
these systems aren't leveraging any
previous experience that they had
and this may be analogous to trying to
have a baby start from scratch for
solving
all sorts of tasks that you may want to
do and so what i'd like to talk a bit
about today is how we might allow
reinforcement learning agents
to leverage previous experience when
they're solving uh
new tasks and this will be especially
relevant and
especially relevant in situations where
we may want the reinforcement learning
agent not to learn one
single task but to learn many different
tasks
and of course this is motivated also by
a lot of the work that i've done in
robotics where
ultimately we don't want a robot just to
do one very narrow thing for us we like
that robot to be broadly useful
now as a second piece of motivation i
think that a lot of times when we think
about exploration we try to build
general purpose algorithms
that will work for a wide variety of
domains and in many ways we think about
using the same exploration algorithm
for a wide range of reinforcement
learning problems ranging from
navigating an environment to making
recommendations to users
to learning a policy for computer system
caching
to learning to physically operate a new
tool or machine
and it doesn't quite make sense to me at
least
use the same exploration algorithm for
these different kinds of
problems especially if you have a means
to
latch on to the particular structure of
a particular domain
such as manipulating objects if you know
that
objects manipulating objects leads to
certain outcomes
or trying to explore an environment in
such a way that that
may allow you to navigate towards a goal
um and in many ways this is how we
currently explore approach exploration
where we try to have a single algorithm
for solving all of these tasks now what
i'm going to talk about today isn't
going to completely sidestep
this overarching exploration problem in
reinforcement learning
but it's going to try to provide a tool
that allows us to leverage experience
from previous tasks
to very quickly explore a new task
so in particular what i want to talk
about is if we can learn exploration
strategies
based on experience from other tasks in
that domain to try to learn a
more domain specific exploration
strategy that can be
even more efficient and more targeted
towards that domain
to explore much more efficiently
okay so uh the ideas that we'll talk
about will build upon the idea of meta
reinforcement learning so i'll first
give a few slides on what meta
reinforcement learning is and then i'll
talk about some of the challenges with
regard to exploration
so the goal of meta-reinforcement
learning is
as follows we want to be able to collect
experience
collect a small amount of experience in
a new markov decision process
from some exploration policy or some
exploration strategy
and then using that experience learn a
policy that solves that mdp
so learn um some procedure that can take
as input
data the data that you've collected
during exploration and
give you a policy that solves that task
uh so this is the goal we want to be
able to essentially do this at test time
or
at meta test time where we want to be
able to solve a new mdp
and the way that meta reinforcement
learning approaches this problem is you
say well
what if we had the ability to collect
experience in other mdps
the goal is to be able to learn how to
efficiently explore and solve
many training mdps such that
when you're given a new mvp you can
quickly explore it and solve it
and so essentially what we're going to
be trying to do is to
learn an exploration strategy and an
exploitation strategy
that will allow us to solve all of the
mdps in our set of meta training tasks
now one key assumption that all metal
learning algorithms
make is that the meta training in the
meta testing mvps
should come from the same distribution
over mdps
and this is this assumption is important
so that we can expect reasonable
generalization
to new mdps at test time
okay so that's generally how the
training setup looks like we typically
assume a set of training mdps
and then we want to be able to
generalize to a new mdp from that same
distribution
a common approach that we'll focus on
today for solving this problem
is to implement the learning procedure
using a recurrent neural network using
kind of a black box
neural network and what this looks like
it might be something like this where
you have this neural network it
takes as input states and rewards that
it receives over time
and produces the next action and the
exploration strategy
and the exploitation strategy is built
into
this model
you might ask well okay is this just a
recurrent policy is this like not really
anything
different from that uh and kind of the
key difference is that the hidden state
is going to be maintained across
episodes within an mdp so they can
remember
the experience that it has learned and
also remember the rewards that is
received as passing as input
and second this recurrent network policy
will be traded across a family
of mdps potentially with varying
dynamics and varying rewards
and it has to infer for a given mdp what
is
what is the strategy for solving that
mdp potentially implicitly learning
something about the reward function and
something about the dynamics
okay so that was a quick kind of primer
on better reinforcement learning
now a sub problem with meta
reinforcement learning is trying to
figure out
how this policy or how this meta policy
should explore the environment when
faced with a new mdp
so the really kind of vanilla approach
to solving this problem
is just to optimize for exploration and
exploitation
end to end with respect to reward
or potentially more specifically with
respect to your kind of overall
regret
and this is really kind of the
widespread approach that's used by most
reinforced meta reinforcement learning
algorithms
and you're essentially just optimizing
that big recurrent neural network such
that
it leads to um to kind of
large cumulative reward and this is nice
in that it's very simple we just have to
train it with regards to this kind of
final objective it also in principle
will lead to the optimal
exploration and exploitation strategy uh
assuming that your current network has
enough capacity and you're off you're
able to actually optimize that
but in practice and also actually in
theory
there's actually a really challenging
optimization when you're faced with a
hard
exploration problem now why is this the
case why is it really hard to learn how
to explore
um to explain this let's look at an
example so
one example a reinforcement learning
problem might look like as
follows say we want a robot to be able
to learn cooking tasks
uh in a new kitchen and so what we do is
we train it across a lot of different
kinds of kitchens
learn many different kinds of tasks
and then after learning in all these
kitchens we want to deploy
the robot in our own kitchen and have it
be able to quickly learn to
cook different things for us in our own
kitchen so this is an example
essentially of a mother reinforcement
learning problem
where we learned how to learn in all of
the training kitchens and then
tried to transfer to the new kitchen net
test time
so this is a pretty challenging
exploration problem because when
if you're in a new kitchen you need to
figure out where all the ingredients are
where all the tools
are and so forth and so you may need to
explore lots of different things
now why might it be hard to learn
exploration strategies that are
effective in this type of situation
so the end-to-end approach is going to
be optimizing for exploration and
execution
end-to-end to maximize reward and
you end up getting this chicken and egg
problem where the execution or the
exploitation it needs to learn how to
cook
and the exploration needs to learn how
to find ingredients
and both of these rely on each other
so if you don't know how to find
ingredients if you have a bad
exploration strategy
then it's going to be hard to learn how
to cook because you don't have enough
information
to solve the task and likewise if you
haven't yet learned how to cook
then that's going to give you very low
reward for any exploration strategy
that you may consider so this is a
we have this sort of coupling problem
which is actually pretty big problem in
practice too
which is that learning the exploration
and the execution depend on one another
and this leads to both potentially local
optimum
in the optimization landscape
and or very poor sample complexity when
you actually try to learn these
end to end
okay so how might we try to address this
challenge
first i'll overview some recent
approaches for
for addressing this and then i'll talk
about an approach that i think is a bit
more satisfying
so one solution to addressing this
chicken and egg problem
is to leverage alternative exploration
strategies
when exploring each new mvp
rather than trying to optimize
exploration end to end
so one example of this might look like
trying to use posterior sampling or
thompson sampling
when faced with a new task so what this
looks like
is these approaches learn a
distribution over a latent variable that
captures the variation in your mpps or
your tasks
and they also learn a corresponding
policy for each of those latent
variables that will solve each of those
tasks
and then once you learn this kind of
latent task variable and the
corresponding task policies
then you can sample from this
distribution from your kind of current
posterior
over your past distribution and then
sample from the
corresponding policies uh so this
basically exactly corresponds to
to thompson sampling except that we're
doing it in this latent space
over the kind of distribution over tasks
that we
over the tasks in our meta training set
or over the tasks that we
or if we've ruled something out over the
kind of smaller set of posterior
distribution so for example if we have
a task distribution where the goal is to
navigate to one of these
circles uh and you only get a sparse
reward when you're
inside a circle so each of these
each of these lighter circles correspond
to different tasks in the task
distribution
and the dark circle corresponds to the
current task
now what this will look like is first
you sample from your prior
over your latent variable and get
trajectories that look like this
then you update your distribution over
over the latent task distribution uh
which will denote with like this
is q5 and then you explore
new uh new directions with the policies
for those tasks
and then eventually you do find a
trajectory that
starts receiving reward and then you
start exploiting that
because your posterior is now kind of
zoned in on the correct task
so this works pretty well in a range of
situations
but there are also situations where
posterior sampling might not work well
so for example uh if the goals are
really far away
and maybe there's a sign on the wall
that tells you what the correct goal is
then posterior sampling isn't going to
look at the sign it's still going to
attempt the task
and this may be arbitrarily inefficient
it as the goals get further and further
away
okay so there are a couple of other
approaches also
other alternative exploration strategies
beyond posterior sampling
so we could use intrinsic rewards in the
inner loop
to explore this was done by this paper
here
we could also try to explore in a way
that recovers the task dynamics or the
task
award and the way that this works is you
train a model
conditioned on the data that you've
collected so far and then you try to
collect
data so that this model is accurate and
this can overcome some of the challenges
of posterior
sampling in some cases and actually lead
to an exploration policy that's much
more efficient that takes a strategy
that looks like this
but of course there are also situations
where this also this won't work well
for example if you have lots of
distractors or a very complex
high-dimensional state space
then learning this model may be very
challenging
and your exploration policy may try to
focus on distractors that vary across
the tasks
and not actually task relevant
information
so essentially these are kind of a
collection of more heuristic approaches
that aren't fairly principled but may be
inefficient when learning to explore so
the upside is that these approaches are
very easy to optimize because they
in some ways decouple the exploration
problem in the inner loop
from the outer meta optimization
and many of them are based on principled
strategies but they can be
sub-optimal by arbitrarily large amounts
in some environment
okay so with this kind of overview of
how metal earning algorithms learn how
to explore
what we want to try to solve is trying
to figure out if we could avoid this
chicken and egg problem
without sacrificing optimality
of our learned exploration strategies
and the answer to this question is yes
we can actually do this and i'll
next talk about some work that was done
by my student evan
that was trying to solve this problem
and the key idea of this approach is
that we're going to try to decouple
the the exploration and the exploitation
by acquiring a representation of task
relevant information
so the way that this works is
in the meta trading process we have a
set of mdps
that we want to learn how to explore and
solve
and first we learn a policy that can
execute each of the tasks and
simultaneously
identify key information about those
tasks
so the way this works is we have some
identifier of the mdp
that may be a one-hot vector or maybe
slightly more descriptive
and we learn an execution policy that
can solve each of our training mdps
conditioned on this mdp identifier
further we also bottleneck the
representation of the mvp identifier
to encourage it to throw away
information in that identifier
that isn't actually relevant for solving
the task for example
changing the wall color things about the
wall color and the decorations are not
relevant for actually solving the task
then we learn how to explore by trying
to recover that
task relevant information and the way
that we do that
is we train an exploration policy so
that it's able
to predict this all next representation
that captures task relevant information
and then once we do these two steps we
can then uh
run our exploration policy this produces
an exploration episode from which we're
able to predict the task relevant
information
which we then pass to the execution
policy
okay so what are the properties of this
approach so
theoretically we tried to look at both
the performance as well as the sample
efficiency of this algorithm
and first we can show that the objective
of this approach is consistent
with the end-to-end optimization under
fairly mild assumptions
and this is really exciting because this
means that we can in principle recover
the optimal exploration strategy
unlike the other approaches that i was
talking about where you use
things like posterior sampling or or
other strategies
and then the second result we were
trying to look at the sample efficiency
of this algorithm
and this is a lot harder to analyze so
we looked at a very simple bandit-like
setting
with a arms and
what it looked like is is in each of the
mvps
mdpi one of the arms yielded a reward
and this arm buried across the mdps
further
in all of these mdps one of the arms
deterministically
revealed which of the arms is the
rewarding arm
so the optimal exploration strategy is
to look at arm 0
which will tell you which arm is the
best one and then to
to pull arm i for that mvp
and we can show that in this very simple
uh
distribution over mdts the end to end
approach requires
at least a squared log a samples for
meta optimization
whereas the dream algorithm requires a
log a at most a log a samples for the
meta optimization
if you assume q learning with a uniform
outer loop exploration strategy
um and so kind of graphically this looks
like this where the dashed line is
showing the theoretical result
and the solid line is showing the
empirical result if you actually run
on this bandit like setting so we see a
pretty huge difference in
the efficiency of these two algorithms
so kind of the takeaway is that dream
allows us both to recover the optimal
exploration strategy
while also being considerably more
efficient to
learn
um i'm a little bit low on time but
empirically this also works
quite well um so we looked at a setting
where
we want to be able to figure out look at
a sign
and use that to determine what the task
is so
the agent will go first look at the sign
realize that it should go to the blue
objects
and then use that during execution to
successfully go to the correct object
and we see this performs much better
than the existing state of the art
meta reinforcement learning algorithms
as well
cool so uh to leave enough time for
discussion
i'll kind of end it there uh
and i'd be happy to take some questions
thank you
yeah thanks chelsea this is really
interesting uh
exploration approached exploration from
a method learning perspective
um now we have some time for questions
from the audience
and panelists
so uh just a quick uh clarification
question if i
um if i think about the reinforcement
learning setting instead of meta
reinforcement learning
then certainly there's been a lot of
recent work about
basically doing exploration in the uh
latent representation that the
agent is learning both empirically and
theoretically and is this
should i think of this as something in
similar space or
is there a bigger difference
yeah that's a good question um
[Music]
so i think that one thing that's that's
pretty different that we can kind of
use when we're actually like analyzing
this is is the fact that we know that
we're
looking at a distribution over mdps
and um
and essentially i guess you can view it
as when you have a distribution over mvp
you're trying to
identify what's different about those
mdps and once you identify what's
different about those mdps
then you're basically done that means
that you've kind of
solved the inner loop exploration
problem you figured out
which mvp that you're in and then after
that
you can you just need to actually have
solved that
individual mmdp so
because of this kind of additional
structure of the kind of
meta rl problem um this allows us to
kind of derive this algorithm that
uh that kind of leverages that structure
to
to work better does that answer your
question
yeah yeah
uh hi chelsea uh uh great talk uh
another question
i mean in general about the meta rl
right so um
you know let's say i have a the base
like lower level reinforcement learning
problem has a horizon like h
or like one over one minus gamma
something like that right
but if i think about uh the horizon of
the meta rl algorithm
the horizon here is actually correspond
to the sample complexity of like solving
and exploring
each lower level uh problem and this is
like similar i guess
you know you have a similar realization
back to this old
you know basically adaptive mdp setting
i think
experience is kind of like a different
instantiation of like the
l uh algorithm and the difficulty we had
like back then was you know the
meta horizon is simply just like too
long
to efficiently optimize uh how do you
think of this difficulty and
or i guess in what circumstances do we
expect that we can
get around with it yeah so i think it
really depends on how hard the
exploration problem
is and i guess also how broader
distribution of tasks is so
basically the horizon of the optimal
like meta policy is going to be the time
it takes to explore
plus the time it takes to actually like
perform that task
and if the exploration phase is well
that's potentially going to be dominated
by the expiration phase because the the
horizon of
to solve the task is just kind of the
horizon of a normal mdp
and the length of that exploration phase
is basically just going to be how long
it takes to identify
which task you're in and so if you have
an extremely broad task
distribution with a lot of tasks it's
going to take a lot of it's going to
take more data to figure out which of
those tasks that you're in
um and if you're if you have a very
narrow task distribution like if you're
just like two tasks for example
then you just have to find the one thing
that kind of distinguishes between the
two
uh the two mvps
in general um in general i think that
it's actually
like for most meta oral problems that we
care about i think it's actually
quite reasonable because uh
like figuring out like discerning
information about an mvp in your task
distribution is usually
not that hard um for example
i guess if uh maybe ever
one situation that we've looked at is we
have a robot the robot is on different
terrains you just need to kind of
probe the environment to find which
terrain you're on and then once you kind
of figure out what terrain you're on
then you're done exploring and you
should just exploit that um
if you're in a setting where maybe
you're a recommendation system and you
want to explore for different users
you essentially need to probe the user
um until you figure out kind of
the sufficient statistics of that user
that allows you to make effective
recommendations for that user
um so i think that basically the
narrower your domain is the
easier it is for um for exploration to
be able to identify the sufficient
statistics of each
of the mdp and i think that this will be
considerably
better than the then basically tabula
rasa exploration because you're not
starting from scratch you have kind of
domain specific knowledge that's built
into your meta rl algorithm
i had a question if i can sneak in
before the time runs out um
so one thing that seems pretty
significant in your ability to sort of
like
efficiently explore new tasks in the
meta rl setting
is that this this idea that the tasks
sort of have like some sort of shared
information so that like
you can sort of like leverage that is
there a way of quantifying that
to have that play into like um sort of
exploration hardness results or like
generalization bounce
yeah so
it's basically it seems like your
question is like can we quantify
the the complexity of the task
distribution essentially
yeah so basically like can you quantify
sort of how much shared information
there is between the tasks
yeah so in the
i guess so if you have n
tasks then you know that you need login
bits to
kind of uh represent the differences
between those tasks
in the um well by kind of coding theory
so that's kind of
one thing if you have an infinite space
of tasks which i think is kind of
the more interesting setting then
it's it's i guess it's harder but i
guess if some tasks share
if their optimal policy is very similar
then the
um then you'd expect it to be kind of
more compressible
i haven't seen any works that that
really study this it certainly seems
interesting and i guess one thing i will
mention is that if you have a completely
random set of tasks
then meta-rl isn't going to buy you
anything because it needs to be able to
pick up on that shared structure
to learn more efficiently if you have
literally a uniform distribution over
tasks then there's
no shared structure and there's nothing
that you can use to more efficiently
explore
luckily in the real world there are many
things that have common structure like
physics the laws of physics and things
that are desirable in general
but yeah i don't know of any works that
have kind of specifically looked at
this problem of of doing it but i would
imagine that
well so it's certainly something that we
can empirically do analytically i think
it's messy because distribution over
mvps maybe
may not even like mvps may not even vary
parametrically
um although perhaps by analyzing the
optimal policies for each of the mvps in
your distribution
you may be able to think about things
more analytically
cool thanks
chelsea i know that um this work is
really it's really interesting and it's
really cool to see it scales
really well too um one question i
wondered about for the bandit results is
um
lee hong and i um a while ago back in
2013
thought some about when there was a
finite set of tasks um for the tabular
setting
um and i was curious whether or not
there might be so in that setting we
were thinking of there being like a
finite set of different types of mvps
and you'd continuously be sampling from
them so you could learn the latent
distribution
and then you could leverage that as sort
of a classification problem later
and that reduced the sample complexity i
wasn't sure in your
case whether the new tasks are always
distinct from all the prior tasks or
whether
you might get repeated tasks in which
case even if there isn't structure among
the tasks you could still
improve learning because you would have
already seen that and you could identify
quickly you've already seen it
yeah so for this specific result the um
it depends on the number of arms in the
bandit and so
i guess this is assuming that if you
have at least have at least kind of a
armed or you have a arms at least a mdps
and this is what the result would look
like um
if you have more than amdp's but still a
arms
then the kind of the complexity results
don't change so
even if you have redundant tasks then
you still get the same um
you'd still get the same result which is
nice
okay um we have maybe one minute for one
last quick question
i'm going to jump in then uh great talk
chelsea this is fantastic
and um regarding the
the material setting and you know um
in exploration there's typically these
pathological examples that show the
importance of a certain approach or
certain technique
i'm wondering have you thought about or
do you have pathological examples
for this case as well saying if you
don't have meta rl if you don't if you
don't like the material perspective
you're going to fail here
so using sorry to clarify you mean
pathological examples for the met like
for this meta rl algorithm or
pathological examples where meta rl like
that better earl overcome
the ladder
um well so like if the tasks themselves
like if you can't figure out how to
solve the individual tasks
then like meta rl isn't going to help
you uh one of the kind of subroutines of
this method was
basically to learn a policy for each of
the
for each of the tasks in your task
distribution conditioned on some
representation of that task
um so in some ways it doesn't really do
anything to sidestep that challenge
uh what it does allow you to do is
um once you have solved those tasks you
can kind of pretty efficiently learn how
to solve new tasks from that task
distribution
and so perhaps one thing that it does
get around
is that if you're trying to solve that
new test task from scratch
then that may be like pathologically
difficult uh whereas meta-rl kind of
leverages this previous set of tasks and
maybe some of those previous set of
tasks have more shaped rewards that
allow you to kind of bootstrap
exploration off of
um that allow you to actually make it
like field attractively solve this new
test task
whereas if you're trying to solve that
test task from scratch you may have had
no hope
um so that's kind of where i see
see it potentially kind of contributing
to the
the broader classical exploration
problem
thank you okay thanks uh chelsea again
um
and now let's move to the